well talks to stop three months of
fighting in Sudan are now reported to
have resumed in Saudi Arabia Sudanese
Army commanders are meeting their
paramilitary Rivals at the rapid support
forces previous negotiations in Jeddah
though were suspended back in June
following repeated ceasefire violations
the battle for power in Sudan has led to
the deaths of at least 3 000 people and
also forced three million from their
homes well let's speak to our
correspondent hibber Morgan she's an
omduman right next to the capital
courtroom here but as we've been saying
there have been multiple tracks of
negotiations with different mediators
none of them seem to be making much
progress so what's now brought everyone
back to the table and Jeddah
well both sides say that they want this
conflict to end that they want to end
the civilian suffering and that they do
not believe that the world should
continue but under different conditions
now you have the military saying that
they want to ensure any process that is
being followed to end the conflict here
in the capital Khartoum and elsewhere
around the country to preserve the
sovereignty of this uh country as well
as to allow for an inclusive and a
comprehensive dialogue that would
include all political parties to lead to
a free and fair elections now that's
something that the rapid support forces
has also been saying but they say that
they don't want members of the former
ruling party to be participating in any
kind of dialogue but both sides are
under extreme pressure the civilian
suffering uh during this past three
months of the conflict has been huge
it's been enormous uh three million
people displaced hundreds of people
missing many people injured access to
medical facilities is an issue and then
there's the situation on both sides on
the ground now the Army has been trying
to regain control of many facilities and
structures here in the capital it's not
been able to do so the rsf has been
trying to get control of the general
command of the military Air Base here in
the city of umbrella and other military
bases around the capital of they've not
been able to do that as well so it looks
it looks like both sides have reached a
position where they believe that
dialogue is the way out instead of
trying to continue militarily if I can
see the smoke Rising there behind you
from what I'm hearing and what we've
been seeing from the Army Chief brohan
it feels though that we're potentially
at a Tipping Point when it comes to the
fighting given that you're saying that
it sounds like a bit of a fighting
stalemate how close are we to an outcome
here
well it doesn't look like with the talk
still progressing it's still ongoing and
indirect talks and that's still
progressing and with fighting here on
the ground it doesn't look like we're
close to uh seeing the end of this war
now the smoke that you referred to
behind me is in the northern part of the
capital Khartoum in the city of Bahrain
it started around 11 A.M local time
that's around 9 A.M GMT and it's been
much larger than that and there have
been several Columns of smoke that we
were able to see from across the Nile
here in the city of umdurman now
fighting has been ongoing mostly today
in the city of Bahrain in the northern
part of the capital Khartoum and it
doesn't seem like it's going to come to
an end soon especially again with the
political talks uh seemingly right now
at the deadlock both sides have to agree
initially on a ceasefire and that is not
something that people feel that they're
close to they continue to hear Heavy
Artillery we continue to hear Heavy
Artillery uh the Antonov planes and the
fighter jets belonging to the Sudanese
Army continues to fly overhead signaling
that this conflict is still very much
ongoing hibber Morgan there with the
latest for us from the ground in
omdroman thank you so much